all right welcome to our endgame class
as per usual I decided which player to
do by asking someone at the front desk
to name a letter of the alphabet today
was d so this is brought to you by the
letter D and also I then go to 2700
chess calm and I find the highest rated
player in the world whose name starts
with D and it turned out it was Mike um
no that wasn't it it turns out it was
Dingley Rin also known as lien ding of
China he's the highest rated player in
China which is surprising because China
has seven players who are twenty seven
hundred feet a are higher and he's the
highest so the Chinese chess players in
general are known for wild attacking
chests and fifty moves of theory at
least so when you think of the strongest
Chinese players with the exception
exception of Wang Yi you think of
tactics tactics tactics okay Wang Yi we
you don't think that he's most boring
player ever so I like him
now it's Engler in one of the few
Chinese grandmasters if not the only one
to play chess and say Louis surprising
Mike comer he planted the spice Cup in
2012 I think I think it's 2012 which I
believe was won by mvl ray go for mvl so
he's I think the only super grandmaster
from China who's played in st. Louis
okay now this game was played in a
Chinese team tournament in 2010 ding
learn was lower rated then this is a
very interesting endgame because white
is up the exchange for a pawn and white
has no past pawns and white can't do
anything ok that means you gotta take it
slow okay you got to slowly improve your
position okay so white played King f1 I
always tell my students someday they'll
listen you should move your King up in
the end game that's the first thing that
white did get his King into the center
ok
and he played rook h3 attacking the pawn
forcing the plunge forward normally
unless your opponent's queening upon in
which case don't follow this advice
you want your opponents pawns that come
forward so you can capture them okay the
opponents are far away the opponent's
the pawn I'm sure you to edit that out
if the pawns are far away it's hard to
capture them because maybe you can't
reach that far
okay for example I can't even reach that
h5 pawn good thing up a mouse okay if
this mouse pad was bigger I could
actually go over here
okay so h5 rook g3 attacking the pawn on
g6 black has no defense right my comer
wait a minute Black has many defenses
that's what I meant King f6 making his
King better h4 now this is something low
rated players never think of it's
stopping their opponents plans and
fixing their opponents pawns now if you
go to a good vet they could fix all the
pawns in one meeting can you have to go
several times right my comer
he's like I even get that joke okay yeah
good audience you got here today they
only like 1% internet got it but there's
only two watching so h4 makes it
impossible for black some movies h5 font
and it makes it terrible to move his g6
pawn so that means we can start
attacking those pawns and they can't
move okay and we want all the pawns on
white squares that way blacks bishop
can't move anywhere because it's blocked
by pawns and whites bishop can take all
the pawns so the fact that black has
these two pawns stuck on white squares
is good for white so h4 is a great move
Bishop e4 nice Bishop rook e3 g3 now
these pawns can never be attacked by the
opposing bishop and it doesn't deter our
bishop from moving so it's a better pawn
structure for white than for black and
eventually white gets his King into the
game and he advances on the Kings side
white sets a little trap let's see who
falls for it who wants to play Bishop
takes f3 that looks like a good movie
wins upon safe 2 again after Bishop f3
who can raise their hand and give a
reasonable move for white Kyle rook f2
right right and now the obvious defense
efore fails terribly to Bishop Ivoire
and not only is this Bishop attacked if
I was in any kids class would be getting
kids they would explain that this pawn
his attack too and half of them would
say this pawn is attacked because that's
how the kids roll okay so we can roll
them out the door that'd be better
all right so black didn't fall for that
black played g5 now we've discussed this
in previous endgame classes but you were
asleep so if you would woken up you
would know what I'm going to say now
when you have the worse or losing
position an endgame you want to trade
all the pawns okay if your opponent has
pawns
they might Queen if your opponent
doesn't have funds and they won't Queen
and this ending obviously Black has the
worst position because White has a rook
for a knight the endgame rooks are much
better than Knights and the opening a
middle game are the Knights better okay
but rooks are really good in the endgame
if Black gets all the pawns off the
board and we have rook and Bishop
against Knight and Bishop that should be
a draw so as long as White has at least
one pawn left he can keep fighting to
win okay white moves his king up takes
takes so black got rid of one pair of
pawns 9 to d7 Bishop b4 black doesn't
want to trade bishops because if he
trades bishops it's hard to defend these
funds over here okay the only defense to
this pawn is the terrible nine to be
eight or c5 which I didn't get to yet
and then obviously rip to b2 which might
come was about to suggest and black has
trouble defending his pawns
now if I was playing black I would
probably play c6 defense okay but you
guys aren't hard made enough to do that
yet
okay so black didn't trade bishops
although black by the trade of bishops
what do I know
okay he played King e6 defense so rook
takes c6 double X clam that move is so
good I probably shouldn't show this
class you're not worthy rug Casey
six does something that's a
transformation takes one winning endgame
it makes an easier winning endgame
now we take all of blacks pawns if you
ask any Grandmaster well not any
Grandmaster but most of them what's
better a rook or a minor piece and two
pawns any beginner will tell you it's
the same because they know they're three
plus two equals five well you're a
grandmaster that math doesn't work three
plus two is much more than five right
Arjun C all right and now in the endgame
pawns go up in value and now black
doesn't have any chance he has to take
the rook he can't save his be pawn and
finally White's going to have a passed
pawn and win now it's Ziggler in decided
not to take this pawn but to take the
other Age pawn you know that's not an H
blond okay so that was probably a good
decision because if black plays Knight G
six he could attack this pawn but if he
can't play Knight G six
why is his not f8 okay so black was like
white said yummy yummy yummy and white
has a bishop for a knight which is
better in the endgame
now those do bughouse players at home
and here don't cry only in regular chess
okay I don't think we have a lot of n
games and bughouse know why we have some
okay speaking of bughouse that's what
the lectures about I saw a buck house
key and that was a draw exactly
my comers like impossible Arjun's like
standing on his chair I know what
happened was that your game Mike Hummer
has ever been so furious
you were what happened you had three
drawn bughouse games I've been playing
bug house for 35 years I've never had a
drawing in okay now the gaming question
I said how do you draw a bug house they
said all the flags were down so I guess
if the flags are all down into draw I
don't know all right so that was yeah
anyway so in bug house black has a
knight but this is real life so White's
winning White has something very
important
that's quite confusing to the new player
you're taught
I in the center play in the center play
in the center however in the endgame you
want your passport passport at the
center because the other person can
block them if you have passed pawns on
the outside there's no way to be stopped
the worst pawn for a knight is an H pawn
or an a pawn when I was a kid we called
them rook puns but since you guys don't
know what that is I just say a and H
puns okay but if you were my age or
older you would know what that's called
okay so here black has no chance because
he has to use all of his pieces to stop
one upon then white can do stuff on the
other side of the board okay II for
following my dictum right you agree okay
argent agrees that's his new word of the
day it stops maybe even the flies like
the lecture it stops it's not enough
anything it tries to trade all the pawns
off okay now as you all know so I don't
know why I'm saying this why am I even
saying this I'm sure
since this endgame started you've only
been thinking one thing now are B's
however a better answer is oh no I have
the bishop and the wrong color trick
pawn what if I lose these two pawns
well if black can trade one pawn and
sacrifice his knife for the other pawn
that's going to be a draw so you have to
be cognizant of that when you're trying
to win these end games if you have the
wrong colored rook pawn you might not
win white played f4 which I'm sure you
all know he would play because white
wants all the pawns on the board the
more pawns the more chances he has to
win in fact I would I would guess if
they traded pawns probably it's a draw
because blacks King could run to the h8
and blacks naik and sacrifice on a3 okay
but if there's three pawns on the board
that's hard to get rid of all of them
blacks he pawn does not look
particularly dangerous to me since white
has two bishop and a king that can stop
it okay King d4 improving his King
bishop EA might as well win the other
pawn to King d3
check King d2 well when you have three
pawns on both sides of the board that
night's going to have a heck of a time
stopping them and whites Bishop easily
stops the e pawn so h5 h6 what a good
plan huh okay and then blacks like wait
a minute this isn't looking so good
so some reason black didn't resign
earlier but now he found a good time to
resign if you play Knight f8 to stop the
pawn this pawn looks pretty good okay so
there's no hope this pawn can't do
anything and even in a crazy world where
white gives us Bishop up for no reason
then white wins easily because White's
pushing this pawn okay so even if black
luckily wins the bishop it doesn't
matter okay so I like that endgame
because white was up an exchange
sacrificed the exchange got an extra
pawn and it was very easy okay next okay
and I think I have to flip the board
hope this is edited out this is terrible
okay these end games I like because it's
two bishops against two knights as a
grandmaster which do I prefer bishops
and as a grandmaster
I prefer even more the fact that black
has an extra pawn an extra pawn two
bishops yeah great okay
unfortunately blacks King is a little
suspicious I'm not sure how blacks King
enters the game at all looks like it
just sits on h7 the whole game so black
has to get a passed pawn black doesn't
have any passed pawns and black has to
get his captive so not so easy white has
a good blockade setup White's Knights
are pretty strong and we've seen in
previous weeks Knights can beat bishops
if the Knights are good and the bishops
are bad okay why play Knight to c7
attacking the a6 pawn what move did
black play Lardon
Bishop's see it is what I would play
because a retreat
I like retreating however I think
bishops see it fails to Knight to Knight
d6 and I don't see how to protect
everything although I've been wrong
before
I don't see what to do though we have to
protect another way RJ is your hand up
are you like resting alright yeah this
should be five right okay now I like the
blockade that White has the knight on c4
can't be driven away and the other
knights attacking the bishop and the
pawn so he played nine takes b5 I don't
like that move okay and the computer
doesn't like it either I think white
should show and tell black how are you
going to win but he played this
straightening out blacks pawns Mike
comers pretty mad now because Mike had
two isolated pawns and now black has
zero and zero is less than two okay
1983 and just like in the previous game
ding liran takes one advantage and gets
another in the previous game he was up
in exchange and sacrificed it and had an
extra pawn in this game he has an extra
pawn but what good is an extra pawn
unless you Queen it and promote it's
hard to promote because they're
blockaded so he did one of your famous
breakthroughs okay he played c4 why did
he play c4 it was explosive very good
okay and whites crashing through on the
queenside b4 how do we stop this B pawn
yeah Knight c2 because that's not my
partner help it yeah okay he played nine
to b5 he wasn't afraid at all Bishop
check b3 that pawn is getting pretty
strong b2 Bishop c5 Knight b1 okay so
white C pawn isn't dangerous at all that
pawn is pretty dangerous more
importantly with the silly night on b1
we can try to move
our king up and white has to go all the
way over here and try to win this pawn
then all of his pawns over here
undefended okay
so white tried to play tricky but he
ended up tricking himself okay after
king g6 he was like being king g5 king
f4 I have to stop that so he made a bad
move
making his demise go quicker played f4
he thought there was a pawn on f4 blacks
king can go to f4 okay so for example
even if you could go to this pawn I mean
I could defend it and if my king gets to
f4 and I play h3 I'm going to take all
your pawns
so why was thinking ahead and he was
like I have to stop that so he lost
quicker than he should have you played
f4 yum-yum-yum-yum and then Bishop
defending the pawn King stops the king
or so he thought king f7 and we go the
other way
so this King can come around this way we
can come through the center we can go
back here if we have to Black has three
avenues to get his King active white
can't stop them all the main thing in
this ending which we saw in the last
ending the night is stopping a passed
pawn so the knight can't do anything the
black Bishop is stopping to pass C pawn
but it can still do a lot of stuff that
Knight can't really go anywhere so
basically why is that a knight
yum-yum-yum take on h4 and yeah now it's
now it's just over and black has several
ways to win one is to just do this and
the Knights trapped which is annoying
and the other is just to Queen over here
because you have more pawns than Wyatt
so white resigned here but that was good
he transformed an advantage of one pawn
into a passed pawn even more important
than passed pawns is how advanced your
past funds are black's pawn is on the
seventh rank White's pawn is on the
fourth rank not not very interesting for
Wyatt pretty interesting for black so
the knight was a good block hater but it
couldn't move another brilliant victory
okay this can we have to flip the board
again even though my comers leaving we
still have to flip the board okay so
here we have a double rook and Bishop
ending black has very suspicious pawns
doubled pawns all right now raise your
hand you can raise your hand at home - I
can see you
which open files does white can white
try to control what are the two
important files for white arjun the C
file in the H file possibly white could
put some rooks on those files okay so in
the game after King g7 white played rook
h2 and then rook h6 making sure the
pawns can never move and then rook h1 so
that was easy now some of you at home
are like wait a minute
this pawns attacked but it's defended
this pawns attack siddhis defended
what's the problem well if you saw
beginner breakdown also known as
beginner beatdown you'll know my comer
suggested and a similar trick Queen
takes Knight on g3 check Queen takes
Knight Shaq and the bishop was pinning
to the King I don't think you were here
for that Arjen you missed that trick so
you can't figure this out what's that
Bishop g6 is the threat winning all of
blacks pawns
now what's good about this is when the
smoke clears okay you hear me Kyle when
the smoke clears the g6 pawn is going to
be hard to defend because my rook is on
the side so black took upon well he
played rook beasts five but White's like
I don't care about that and now he took
the pawn on g6 winning all the pawns on
the Kings side the H pawn is pinned not
only is it pinned you not only blunder
your rook and when I say your rook I
hope French is watching this because
it's only the exchange you not only lose
your rook but man this checkmates
annoying okay so you don't want you
don't have any of that happen okay so he
played eight eggs b4 and then he played
ripped eggs before
Bishop takes h7 taking all the pawns
black put them in Shack white saw it and
when they trade all the pieces off it's
not good now here a black played for a
trick although I think White's winning
after this trick that trick is something
that's needs a thank you I don't think
that trick works so he just took the
bishop I'm guessing if he takes the rook
black plays check and wins the rook and
probably white still winning right yeah
I think I think white has good winning
chances here yeah I would think White's
winning okay so that trick doesn't work
so that's what you know you're in
trouble when your tricks don't work
Julian knows what I'm talking about
alright so he took out the bishop now
there's no defense of this d6 pawn
unfortunately
it's like a domino effect so if you're
good at dominoes you should win this
position with Wyatt
once you take the pawn on d6 b6 is
hanging d7 is hanging your position
falls apart okay yum-yum-yum
and now again the Chinese players in
general are very good at tactics and
calculating and tricks and if you have a
trick that wins the super grandmasters
will find it okay so if you're playing a
blitz kiemce you'd probably move your
rook probably to e6 because it Forks the
King and pawn after pawn takes rook
you're like no I know the palm is going
the other way okay in which case you'd
still be lost okay
so instead white played the trickiest
move ever recommended by Run DMC and
later recommended by Aerosmith yes g6
okay also recommended by you know the g6
and the g7 later okay I mean the boys
ever talked about g6 and g7 in the same
sentence alright g6 threatening yeah you
get to Queen the pun now King takes rook
is risky because of this okay and so
blacks in a lot of trouble
black chose the only way out Arjun I
can't I can't
no no rookie six works in this position
hold on hold on
that's good lecturing what would the
Germans say about rookie six does that
work
Julie or would they say no yeah you
could play rookie nine which is also
recommended by the Germans
rookie nine you move where to age six
you mean Oh after yeah that's the best
move that's right yeah rookies rookie
three is the best move but instead of
playing it he resigned if he plays your
k3 yum-yum-yum-yum-yum and I'm too old
to count how many pawns White is ahead
but it's a lot okay at the super
Grandmaster level when you're two or
three or four pawns ahead then you're
going to win I mean usually usually
I heard today there was some trick
thomashefsky rock Evancho didn't decal
famine okay resigns resigns resigns two
days ago well that's old news okay now I
like this endgame a lot because you know
a lot of people are telling saying
Bishop opposite colors is always a draw
which is the opposite of my rule it's
always a win here Black has several
advantages black is up upon and white
has two isolated pawns and whites attack
white black is attacking White's King so
black has lots of advantages okay now
here Dingley rim was playing a better
player and I'm going to mispronounce it
but luckily certain people left who can
you know can call me on it so I can
pronounced any way I want
boos youngji you agree right yeah that's
it yeah
that's what I said yeah I was close yeah
no I pronounced it perfect better than
perfect
yeah there we go yeah yeah exactly
exactly yeah yeah we know we know yeah
yes okay yeah and the strange news is
he's North Korean so he's trying to get
some good chess knowledge here and bring
it back to one of the top chest nations
No all right so okay now Dingley reign
is now better than blue but not when
this game was playing now white played
Knight g3 attacking the rook but black
saw that try to get up to the seventh
rank then puts terrible pressure on the
f2 pawn I hate when that happens
Knight f5 also known as knife f5 h5
stopping him from playing Knight takes
HX h4 h4 follows an important rule that
I've already said twice today and the
last week and the week before you didn't
watch the one two weeks ago so go back
in the video queue and put it up there
let's see Arjun video Q how do you spell
Q and close enough there are only three
or four mistakes okay what's that I but
I give a sentence you're not paying
attention yes that's a better answer
now you're talking now you're better
than ninety nine point nine nine percent
of Americans and point one percent of
British people okay so but that's okay
because you're better than them for
other reasons
alright okay so black took because it's
a free pawn now just kidding Knight
takes h4 okay now what does black have
now that he didn't have last move you he
has a past age pawn put it in H okay
rook a to with a subtle threat all right
now most of the people are wondering why
did black hang his bishop the answer is
he didn't see it and his opponent didn't
see it right Ben what you have the right
answer here huh rook to ha1 almost
checkmate
not quite but almost checkmate in a
couple moves okay
so we can't play rook takes e5 and
allowing rook takes F to a bishop takes
F to is risky so he played f3 what's
wrong with f3
you never play f3 right ok that's one of
my rules I'm like half kidding
okay now I actually see a tactic here
but without using my computer that means
it won't work so people on the interview
like that loses seven pieces what are
you doing so Rick seats who allows the
same a right a one mate ok this move
I've refuted by using my head not a good
idea and this is my ideas takes a 93
check and a one-minute game I'm
certainly right
I might even be right in here but I
don't know anyway that would be cool if
that happened but that didn't happen
ok f3 sir yeah we discussed that but you
forgot rook c2 rook a1 checkmate yeah ok
ok proving you're not an elephant
because elephant never forgets
ok so instead f3 never play f3 Bishop a7
this prevents rook takes c5 if you're if
you didn't notice that at home you can
write a note now I'll wait no five five
not seven rook takes e5 ok all right now
white played Knight f5 also known as
knife f5 King age 7 got to advance your
King in the end game walking into
discovered check the first move Julian
would have thought of okay but you got
to walk your King up Kings gone up here
solid ok and discover checks do nothing
93 discovered check King g7 Knight of
the center rook check which way - Dwight
play King G 1 or King he won
wait I just said discovered checks do
nothing go to g1 fall for my tricks do
you kinky one is safer okay 9g to check
now I know you're not very good at home
but you can get this one right
what did white do ah they say King takes
f2 I can't believe it uh you know King
d1 okay now if I was white I would have
castled confusing my opponent see told
you Wow well that happened Wow
that's why we have an editor who left
crying hi
so h4 why would you play h4 Julien put
it in H exactly okay if you don't
understand that at home and you don't
watch every episode of The Simpsons ever
and then you'll understand it okay then
you'll get that okay rook c2 rook takes
King tanks now again you guys are all
like obviously colored bishops who draws
okay and I don't know why you guys have
funny voices like that
maybe you could go to the doctor get
some kind of surgery exactly no no no
please please you give me too little
credit
okay now White's King not so good for
stopping this pawn I'm the first to
admit if White's King was on h2 or h3
Black's not going to win but White's
King is on c2 so black is going to win
h3 putting it in H once again f4 f5 my
favorite move of the game never play f6
always play out five now Bishop takes
Knight pawn takes Bishop Black's going
to have an extra Queen Bishop takes up
five h2 Black's going to have an extra
Queen and the obvious Bishop f3 runs
into which trick remember tricks are for
kids
eggs and the kids are raising their
hands you at home don't understand
the two kids raising your hands and then
the adults their furring their brow and
of a Nutella stay in the situation I'll
call on the oldest kid Julian
91 Shaq BAM attacking the King and
Bishop so here black did what we all
like to do in the or white did white
resigned okay why did black win that
game black had a past age pawn now one
of my favorite chess coaches if not my
favorite is John fedora wits also known
as fedorov itch and John told me once
when discussing one of his games and I
said what do you think of this position
you know because he was showing a game I
didn't know who was better and he said I
don't know who's better but I got to
pass pawns and I'm pushing them and he
pushed them and and to pass pawn he won
so I don't know who's better here but I
like this past fall in the sixth ranked
that's about to make a queen if you want
to win an endgame
you should make a queen right otherwise
you're not going to win first of all
none of you nominee a bishop at night
especially Julian and Joe especially
okay maybe with bishop at night come on
nobody can do that you know there's no
such people I figured Venetian okay now
last but not least this one this is my
favorite of all the egg games and the
reason is black was worse or losing but
he won usually in lectures when they
talk about a player or an idea they say
look at this idea White's winning this
is how white wins or they say look at
this player he played great in he won
well that's not the truth and the truth
hurts truth is sometimes you're worse or
you're losing you guys all know what I'm
talking about every game you ever play
right and you've got to win those games
okay if you don't win those games you're
going to lose the games that you're
losing don't do that okay anybody can
win when they're winning you got to win
when you're losing
now this ending the whole ending blacks
been worse but this is a double edge
position first of all whites upon a head
second of all white
as a passed pawn that's further advanced
than blacks past pawn okay on the other
hand White's extra passed pawn is
worthless and if you don't believe me
you can ask John schranz okay hopefully
Peter and Kelly are watching this video
two people on earth can get that jokes I
hope they're watching okay well you
can't get it you're not one of those two
people yeah that was the most inside
joke ever two people can get it out of
seven billion okay but they'll get it so
if they're watching it's for you guys so
White's extra pawn is worthless is that
G three pawn going to Queen are those
four pawns better than those three pawns
they could be in the future but not now
now blacks King and blacks bishop are
doing a reasonable job of stopping to
see pawn white has nothing stopping the
a pawn
so even though White's better all three
results are possible double forfeit
cheating with a computer and both
players die those are the three possible
results okay let's see which one happens
look C for attacking the c6 pawn and
white immediately makes a mistake he
plays Bishop c5 and this is a confusing
mistake because it looks like the best
move but it's actually a bad move a four
now White's in trouble because why can't
do anything doing stuff is good he can't
move his C pawn because black takes it
he can't move his bishop because black
takes the C pawn and he can't move his
rook because I'll take your bishop so
you can't move anything you can't move
any of your pawns so you can't move
anything that's not good if you write
that down at home can't move anything
not good okay so shockingly he played
King f1 King f1 is the losing move you
incorrect
very risky because black might see
bishop takes a five yeah but no but if
he doesn't see you then you're good yeah
usually people miss for treating bishop
moves they don't see the bishops go
backwards you hear me talking Matt
Larson him at Larson's be talking you
know know why shouldn't lose this now I
made a bad move okay
White has one week pawn on the Kings
side Julian who raises him before the
question was asked yeah I know you have
another thing to say
Bishop where exclam after Bishop e1
white is better that's correct
so yes okay this should be one is good
for several reasons what we're getting
to now and the question was after King
f1 the losing move which white pawn is
now week on the kingside that one yeah
no he's right Arjun helped him out
G pun therefore the best move which will
shock everybody are you singing down at
home
King each three obviously because you
put it in H the King on h3 stops all
checks and defends the g3 pawn now the
g3 pawns not defended you might be
saying who cares if he attacks it all
defendant plays rook c3 I'll defend my
pawn well we have a double attack some
would call it a fork I wouldn't call it
a fork with some wood rook takes g3 is a
threat if white defends it Black has a
very unusual winning move why black has
another threat anyone yes
83 is good and might win maybe that's
even better than my move but I think
rugby 3 is scary I think your moves
better yes
then I would recapture yeah that's not
good for Wyatt then all of white spawns
are hanging and the be three pawns too
strong I would win a thousand moves okay
because if your King goes over here to
stop my be pawn this Bishop takes all
these pawns
yeah but I'm going to move my King over
there right yeah
Bishop e7 after King somewhere you could
but that then White's better yeah well
but I could take the bishop but I'm
better this pawn I can just stop okay
so he didn't want rook b3 to happen or
a3 to happen so he played Bishop b6
trading everything off or so he thought
rook b3 anyway okay now it's tough it's
rough I tells you okay so he played rook
c5 let's analyze the endgame we were
talking about takes takes Bishop d4
let's go here because that looks like
fun
okay now my plan is to do this move my
king up if your King goes over here to
stop me I'm going to play Bishop f2 and
take about seven pawns take the pawns
from off the board put them on and take
them this pawn structure on the Kings
side really favors black and this Bishop
ending so after route b3 the tables have
turned
rook c5 yum-yum-yum-yum-yum takes and
now this is the key position of your
life I'm not even talking about chess
your whole life this is the only move
you ever have to find you can retire
after this move half the people here are
sure the way black played and about
ninety percent don't know it's a slow
audience by eighty percent of them is
slow the other forty percent are pretty
good okay here black only has one move
that any master or above would consider
nobody here is a master so you can't
find it
no no you have a chance it's called luck
okay not good luck dumb luck let's call
on our favorite student Joe Gagne with
the correct answer rook a six rooks
belong behind passed pawns if it was
White's move white would play rook a
seven and have no trouble at all after
rook a six White has a lot of trouble
because black has a very easy plan Queen
the pawn and why it's going to have the
worst rook ever which is what happened
okay now white can't do anything all
white can do is stop blacks King from
moving but he's good to get zoogs wand
out so now black can't move his king
forward so they agreed to a draw no I'm
not just kidding yeah now black resigned
because he wanted to make white feel
better because white was winning earlier
all right
so black made a waiting move rook a
eight I would have saved energy and
played rook a seven one less square and
the closer to the clock to right
who Rick a fight but rook a five that's
like an accurate is king before yeah now
Rick a seven yeah Rick a it's the worst
even Rick a4 is closer to the clock okay
and after Rick a a white has to move
that's unfortunate
if White's rook moves this pawn keeps
coming if blacks King moves anywhere I'm
going to move my King in somewhere where
you're not going to like it
okay so I assume white resigned here and
I'm wrong as usual now no matter how
much I look I can't find the moves that
doesn't win I think King D for weight is
removed it doesn't win hold on hold on
yeah but I'm better there now maybe I'm
not better yeah you're right I'm worse
there yeah all right okay so Rick G it
was played no I'm kidding Arjen have a
seat all right
so King e for King C for was also good
King b1 based on what rule always play
King b1 now the purpose of king b1 is to
give away
to move the rook and then your king goes
to a one if you play King b3 you can't
be moving your rook everywhere what am i
doing because a2 a1 okay so now white
gets his rook active and black has no
hope now if you guys were playing you
would be taken pawn after pawn and you
might win however white is defenseless
against the capturing of all of his
pawns
however agreed however black can easily
defend against White's only threat this
is called having patience if you don't
have patience you could ask Axl Rose and
he'll hook you up
agreed yeah I agree yeah yeah
and then if my comer was teaching
welcome to the jungle right okay
so black played the obvious move Julian
rook e8 now White has a lot of counter
play no counter play okay now black will
take pawns at his leisure very leisurely
so black went from a pawn down in the
endgame to upon ahead blacks King is
better than whites black has more passed
pawns than white and blacks King is
going to take all the pawns white did
the only thing he could do resigned and
black won the game so that was
interesting we saw the two most
important things in these end games King
activity and how strong your past pawns
are blacks passed a pawn was pretty
strong White's passed C pawn black just
took it had no problem
nothing nothing to see here and whites
majority on the Kings side he couldn't
do anything with it because it was
blockaded so a very good win from a
worse position as Julian pointed out
right as usual a bishop II won and white
would have well probably a draw but
White's better white would have won for
sure then you would never have seen this
game because yeah who's looking at these
games right okay well I hope you enjoyed
our lecture I did don't forget send the
largest donation because know
donation is too large to the chess club
and scholastic center or to bend
Feingold either way is good but don't
send one to Bend Simon don't do that
okay those that know that's terrible
because then he'll be in a higher tax
bracket ought to see his tax attorney
student loans want more money even
though you pay them off it'll be
terrible yeah all right and as Gene
Wilder said a one of the first scenes of
Young Frankenstein class is dismissed
hey they clapped for him too
you saw that movie yesterday